chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de fine stratégie peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous y
retrouver nous sommes ensemble comme
chaque jour désormais du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire ce soir joe biden et son
administration pourront ils se relever
du fesc aux afghans l'europe lâché par
l'allié historique américain se retrouve
bien esseulé à la veille du départ
définitif des troupes de l'oncle sam
l'onu tenait cet après midi un concert
une réunion au conseil de sécurité la
france et le royaume-uni plaide avec le
soutien de moscou pour une zone afghane
sécurisé mais les talibans rejettent
catégoriquement cette option
face sanitaire obligatoire pour près de
2 millions français en ce lundi de
rentrée des salariés au contact du
public devront présenter ce sésame
pourtant controversé jusqu'à quand et
avec quelle sanction prévue pour les
réfractaires une nouvelle étape dans le
calendrier de gestion de la crise
sanitaire alors qu'en parallèle bruno le
maire annonce la suppression du fonds de
solidarité au 30 septembre
la crise sanitaire justement aura-t-elle
un impact sur la campagne présidentielle
qui s'annonce déjà féroce le compte à
rebours est lancé dans 34 semaine passée
aimant les français voteront pour le
prochain président de la république
à droite la dispersion semble avoir déjà
fait ses premières victimes
seul cheval de bataille commun tous
résister aux chants de l'abstention pour
ne pas répéter les bérézina des
régionales la rentrée politique ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face en deuxième
partie d'émission à 21h
[Musique]
et pour commencer ce soir reportage
exclusif au coeur d'un kaboul éventré
par une attaque de des ch mourad 15e et
khaled el des radars thé international
ont recueilli le témoignage des
survivants de l'attentât suicide survenu
jeudi à l'aéroport de kaboul dans un
chaos difficilement descriptible
regarder aubry fin nous avons entendu
différentes versions et certains de ces
gens là sont encore sous un choc
certains ne peuvent pas bien longtemps à
cause de l'explosion et de la fusillade
une femme en particulier n'entend plus
rien d'eux l'aurait droite depuis trois
jours
mais après avoir recueilli toutes ces
versions nous pensons avoir maintenant à
tableau plus claire de ce qu'il s'est
passé ce jour-là de cet incident
meurtrier survenu à la porte nord de
l'aéroport de kaboul
selon les témoins les troupes
américaines là bas s'étaient placés en
ligne devant la porte nord épaule contre
épaule est le kamikaze de dèche qui a
fait exploser son dispositif avait
réussi à s'approcher au plus près d'eux
à seulement quelques mètres
autour de lui il y avait une foule j'ai
déjà décrit l'affluence à l'aéroport de
kaboul et dans ce cas là c'était la même
chose les gens étaient compressés
ounces vesti lorsque son gilet explosif
a été actionné ça a été un enfer
les gens se sont mis à courir dans tous
les sens y compris vers l'aéroport en
essayant de fuir pour trouver un refuge
quelque part c'était la panique
et c'est à ce moment là que les troupes
américaines selon les témoignages
ouvert le feu sur la foule il s'agit de
troupes qui se trouvaient sur les murs
autour du point métro et à l'entrée de
l'aéroport où l'attentât suicide a eu
lieu
c'était quelque chose de nous vivons à
kaboul depuis vingt ans voire plus
je n'ai jamais rien vu de pareil
cela nous faisait mal aux yeux
nous avions les yeux qui pleurait
oui et aussi nous ne pouvions pas
respirer il n'y avait pas d'oxygène
après cela les américains ont commencé à
nous tirer dessus
je veux dire ils ont ouvert le feu sur
des gens
veulent c'est des gars dit qu'ils ont
commencé à tirer de façon indiscriminée
sur des gens qui tentaient de s'échapper
qui sautait dans un canal rempli d'eau
qui coule on a des murs du périmètre de
l'aéroport
beaucoup de ces gens selon les médecins
auxquels nous avons parlé un médecin
nous a donné des informations
officieuses qu'il a obtenu de son
collègue d'un autre hôpital beaucoup de
gens ont été blessés par des éclats
d'obus et en même temps ont reçu des
blessures par balles noma comme beaucoup
d'autres n'ont pas été blessés mais ont
été piétinées et sont morts étouffés
d'un traumatisme écrasé par la foule
crise de panique
les troupes américaines encore une fois
il s'agit de témoignages ont continué à
tirer un long temps après cette
explosion parce que les militaires
étaient préoccupés ils avaient peur tu y
avoir d'autres kamikaze parmi la foule
des copies mau soc album et cela a été
bien sûr aggravée par la foule prise de
panique qui couraient dans tous les sens
y compris vers les troupes qui tirait de
farine troupes à la doc le médecin de
service des urgences à kaboul auxquelles
nous avons parlé a confirmé que beaucoup
de victimes à avait des blessures par
balles
de bris av
nous avons contacté le pentagone nous
avons posé des questions concernant ces
nouvelles accusations ces nouveaux
témoignages le pentagone a dit qu'il
mène l enquête comme ils le font
toujours dans ce genre de situation
je me rappelle que quand nous étions à
mossoul en irak où les états unis ont
mené une campagne de bombardements
aériens il y avait des habitations où
après un seul raid aérien jusqu'à 100
civils avaient été tués cv leinster se
vit cette veste est gay ces enquêtes
peuvent prendre vraiment beaucoup de
temps pour ne pas avoir de confirmation
du fait d'un très bonne avant un an
voire plus longtemps peut-être de golf
foyers au pape ses mots et aujourd'hui
encore les menaces à l'aéroport de
kaboul reste réel et précise déclaration
ce soir même du pentagone à la veille du
retrait définitif des soldats américains
présents en afghanistan
ce matin plusieurs roquettes ont été
tirées des tirs revendiqués par le
groupe terroriste état islamique au
khorassan et interceptées par le système
antimissile américain françois hisquin
beach
un combattant taliban montent la garde
devant la carcasse d'une voiture
détruite c'est depuis ce véhicule que
des roquettes visant ce lundi matin
l'aéroport de kaboul aurait été tiré
j'étais à l'intérieur de la maison avec
mes enfants et d'autres membres de la
famille soudain il ya eu des explosions
nous avons sauté dans l'enceinte de la
maison et nous nous sommes allongées sur
le sol une nouvelle attaque en direction
de l'aéroport
confirmée par washington à la veille du
départ prévu de l'armée américaine
dont les dernières évacuations se
déroule dans un climat particulièrement
tendu
quelques heures plus tôt l'armée
américaine réalise une frappe aérienne
contre un véhicule chargé d'explosifs se
dirigeant vers l'aéroport de la capitale
afghane une action contre le groupe etat
islamique en plein milieu d'habitations
qui aurait fait plusieurs victimes
civiles
nous sommes au courant que des victimes
civiles ont été annoncées à la suite de
notre frappe sur un véhicule à kaboul
nous sommes toujours en train d'évaluer
les résultats de cette frappe qui nous
le savons henry menace imminente de
l'oica contre l'aéroport
ce qui s'est passé n'est pas clair et
nous continuons d'enquêter c'est la
seconde opération américaines depuis
l'attentât de l'aéroport de kaboul
samedi une frappe de drone dans l'est de
l'afghanistan a tué deux membres de haut
niveau de la branche afghane du groupe
etat islamique et blessé un troisième d
action condamnée par les talibans à
présent que les américains quittent
notre pays ils doivent respecter notre
indépendance
parce que c'est notre pays d'un outil
détenons le pouvoir s'il ya une menace
nous devons être au courant afin d'y
faire face d'enquêté ou si nécessaire de
mener des opérations contre elle les
américains ne peuvent rien faire de leur
côté nous les condamnons ne peuvent pas
mener de telles opérations
ils doivent cesser ils n'ont aucun droit
de faire de telles opérations en
afghanistan
notre indépendance doit être respectée
main sur le coeur
le président américain a accueilli ce
dimanche les dépouilles des treize
soldats américains tués dans l'attentât
du 26 août joe biden vivement critiqué
par les républicains pour sa gestion de
la crise afghane
l'une des pires décisions de politique
étrangère de l'histoire américaine selon
l'influent chef des sénateurs
républicains mitch mcconnell
washington qui réunit ce lundi en
visioconférence et partenaires clés afin
de discuter d'une approche aligné pour
la suite des opérations
alors que l'onu tiendra une réunion des
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité
il est justement propos de cette réunion
alors que la france et le royaume-uni
craignait un veto de la russie ce soir
lors de la tenue de ce conseil de
sécurité le crem en définitive apporté
son soutien à la création d'une zone
protégée de quoi faire taire les
spéculations autour d'une diplomatie
russe soit disant réfractaires aux
pourparlers des nations unies la
correspondance à moscou de vera goffman
la proposition d' emmanuel macron sur la
création d'une zone protégée à kaboul
doit être discutée a déclaré le porte
parole du kremlin dmitri peskov elle a
également souligné qu'il était crucial
de comprendre l'attitude des taliban à
l'égard de cette initiative je vous
propose d'écouter
bien sûr c'est une proposition qui doit
être discuté il est très important de
discuter ici de toutes les modalités
d'une telle zone de son régime de
fonctionnement et surtout il est crucial
de comprendre l'attitude des taliban à
l'égard disons de l'idée de créer une
telle zone
qui dit qu'accor
mettrait peskov a aussi évoqué le statut
juridique des talibans en russie ce
mouvement est considéré comme une
organisation terroriste dont les
activités sont prohibés selon le crir
elle est donc encore trop tôt pour
redéfinir ce statut il faudrait d'abord
observer les premières actions concrètes
du nouveau gouvernement afghan encore
plus givry même temps que parce qu'on ne
va plus
il est encore prématuré de poser cette
question vous savez que le président
poutine et le ministère des affaires
étrangères nos collègues ont déjà dit
que bien sûr il faudrait regarder quels
seront les premiers actes du
gouvernement qui sera formé
n'oublions pas que la structure de
gouvernance n'a même pas encore été
formé
pour le moment une étape très difficile
est en cours liés à l'achèvement de
l'évacuation des étrangers et des
afghans qui ont décidé de quitter le
pays
un autre processus dangereux est en
cours en lien avec la présence de
groupes et d'éléments terroristes sur le
territoire de l'afghanistan
par conséquent il est très important de
voir quels seront les premiers actes des
talibans pour diriger l'afghanistan
ensuite il sera déjà possible de tirer
des conclusions
québec
les bonnes dans une interview accordée à
radio france le 29 août le porte-parole
du mouvement islamiste a qualifié la
proposition de la création d'une zone de
sécurité ce contrôle luzien avancée par
le président français de non nécessaire
parce que l'afghanistan est un pays
indépendant et sans 16000 personnes
évacuées par un gigantesque pont aérien
depuis le 14 août depuis donc la prise
de kaboul par les talibans
il reste moins de 48 heures aux
américains pour rendre les clés aux
talibans les évacuations se poursuivent
le tout dans un climat extrêmement tendu
cinq roquettes ont encore été tirées
aujourd'hui alors comment expliquer
cette débâcle américaine qui pousse des
milliers de personnes à quitter
l'afghanistan notamment en direction de
l'europe que vont devenir ces réfugiés
que l'amérique va accueillir de manière
partielle décryptage de ce fiasco avec
nos invités
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison avec nous également
mériadec raffray journaliste spécialiste
des affaires militaires des questions
défense vous êtes l'auteur également du
livre afghanistan les victoires oublié
de l'armée rouge aux éditions economica
de 2010 avec plaisir bonsoir à vous
également réunion donc du conseil de
sécurité ce soir à la france qui plaide
on l'a dit pour la création d'une zone
protégée dans la capitale afghane sur le
plan diplomatique vous connaissez très
bien la question claude blanchemaison
est ce que cette proposition selon vous
à d a des chances d'aboutir à
aujourd'hui c'est bien possible parce
que comme vous savez conseil de sécurité
des nations-unies tout dépend de la
position des cinq membres permanents et
la proposition de créer une season comme
on dit à l'onu vient de la france et la
grande-bretagne les etats-unis
soutiennent parce que ça viendra adoucir
un petit peu le côté abrupt du retrait
américain et le fait que en effet les
évacuations ne sont en réalité pas
terminée la russie vient de dire ce soir
que c'était une bonne idée et qu'elle
appuyait cette proposition est là non
plus ça n'est pas très étonnant parce
que si on regarde les diverses
propositions du président poutine depuis
deux ou trois ans et il a à plusieurs
reprises proposé un sommet des membres
permanents des cinq membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité pour discuter des
sujets les plus difficiles
la france aussi avait proposé ce à un
moment donné il se trouve que les autres
pays n'en veulent pas et donc il n'y a
pas eu de sommets mais aujourd'hui c'est
une occasion de montrer l'importance que
peut jouer le conseil de sécurité sur
certaines qui restent les chinois les
chinois peuvent être tentés par
évidemment un coût mais qui dont le prix
serait très élevé qui est de soutenir
les talibans qui à priori ne veulent pas
de cette zone est effectivement les
chinois pourraient essayer de créer
un sentiment de confiance entre les
talibans eux en protégeant les talibans
et en mettant leur veto à la création de
cette zone je ne crois pas qu'il le
fasse et je crois qu'ils sont en réalité
en mesure d' assouplir la position des
talibans ou peut-être de servir
d'intermédiaire parce que les talibans
ont des choses à demander ils veulent
deux choses ils veulent la
reconnaissance internationale or tous
les pays occidentaux ont dit on va voir
en fonction de ce que font les talibans
on les reconnaîtra on les reconnaîtra
pas ils veulent être reconnus et puis
deuxièmement l'argent les banques sont
fermées depuis le 13 août les gens
manifestent dans les rues dimanche
dernier les gens protestaient à kaboul
parce qu'ils n'ont plus d'argent ils ne
peuvent plus aller retirer l'argent au
guichet de la banque et les réserves de
la banque centrale sont gelés à
washington donc il ya peut-être des
éléments qui permettent d'espérer
d'avoir une résolution 7 mai on suivra
ça en tout cas on aura des nouvelles
pendant la nuit
c'est étonnant cet axe russie qui est
d'accord avec le royaume-uni la france
et la france 1 ça faisait longtemps on
le doit quoi à la débâcle américaine du
coup finalement se rapproche alors
écoutez moi je ne parlerais pas de des
black américaine je parlerai
d'opérations cynique qui a failli
tourner à la crise à la véritable crise
voire même au chaos opération cynique
parce que les américains ce n'est pas
une surprise pour ceux qui suivent le
dossier ne sont pas partis du jour au
lendemain ils ont en quelque sorte vous
parliez du 10e sur ambassadeurs que les
chinois allaient peut-être donner enfin
que les talibans souhaité une
reconnaissance internationale en réalité
ils l'ont obtenue d'une façon magistrale
à partir de 2018 quand ils se sont assis
la table négociations avec les
américains à doha au qatar sous l'égide
d'ailleurs de leurs amis qatari est
également pakistanais et il obtenu avec
sa fameuse accords de février 2020 qui
en réalité préparer officiellement le
retrait et
pour revenir à votre question sur la
réussite
des balles pièce combat justement
analysé avec vous le mot exact on
viendra sur la manière un peu si vous
voulez dont les rues sont vus cette
opération américaine en tout cas pour
les rues je croirais monsieur
l'ambassadeur ne me démontera pas
démentira pas pardon les russes veulent
absolument pas que le cas où
s'instaurerait à kaboul ils veulent
gérer la pression
éventuel futur de terroristes jihadistes
vers le nord ils veulent pouvoir
également gérer la problématique de la
frontière
concernant les stupéfiants ce qui est
fou c'est qu'en 2001 un mot quand même
en 2001 comme quand les talibans sont
chassés par les américains le trafic de
drogue a quasiment disparu car les
talibans avaient éradiqué quasiment le
la culture de cocaïne et de pavot et
bien aujourd'hui parce que les
britanniques en particulier mais aussi
les américains ont laissé faire c'est un
véritable problème donc je pense que les
russes veulent tout faire pour contrôler
la situation et en rien ou même des
intérêts communs aujourd'hui un troll et
les français et les anglais qui se
retrouve quand même bien esseulé disons
que ça permet voilà ça permet de bonnes
et de modérés entre guillemets la
position américaine ou le va-tout
américain où la carte jetés par les
etats-unis et par joe biden qui soit dit
en passant est une carte qui reprend
toutes là à s'hydrater j américaines en
afghanistan depuis plusieurs années
alors justement on va en parler
de cette stratégie américaine on va
écouter d'abord pierre lellouche un
ancien secrétaire d'état un saut nicolas
sarkozy d'ailleurs l'ancien représentant
de la france pour l'afghanistan et le
pakistan
regardez comment ils nomment justement
cette opération américaine le fiasco
américain en afghanistan marque l'échec
définitif du state building donc voilà
c'est court c'est efficace selon lui
fiasco américain que l'on blanchemaison
vos emplois leurs employeurs y ait le
même terme
je ne sais pas je pense que les
américains sont allés en afghanistan
pour naturellement
venger le 11 septembre enfin il fallait
que les américains réagissent première
attaque sur le sol américain les
milliers de morts en plein en plein new
york et effectivement ils n'ont eu aucun
mal à réunir une coalition il n'eut
aucun mal non plus à avoir l'appui
politique de la russie et à l'époque
tout le monde était d'accord pour que
cette coalition a cherché à y débusquer
les auteurs de cet attentat qui était
abritée par par les talibans cela dit
une fois ben laden tué
pourquoi continuer cette opération
l'objectif de guerre était atteint et à
ce moment là on a eu un brouillage on a
eu un certain nombre de bruit américains
disent rabat oui mais il faudrait
peut-être construire une nation
démocratique en afghanistan faire du
nation building est effectivement avec
la connaissance assez sommaire que les
américains avaient de l'afghanistan eh
bien c'était voué à l'échec et en effet
les russes qui ont été en afghanistan
pendant une dizaine d'années auparavant
en savait quelque chose alors
aujourd'hui on dit c'est le tour des
chinois peut-être que les chinois on
s'entendre avec les talibans eh bien on
leur souhaite bonne chance mais il ya
des cafres et échecs du state building
fiasco américain en disiez non c'est pas
exactement le clos que les gens par m
enfin quand même déjà en termes de
retrait on peut quand même appelé sa
débâcle j'allais dire il faut distinguer
ce qui vient de se passer c'est là cette
séquence depuis le 2 juillet où les
américains nuitamment au quitté
l'aéroport de bagram sur laquelle il les
avait
en fait quelques dizaines une dizaine de
milliers d'hommes et qu'il devait
évacuer donc 2 juillet il ferme la
lumière et 14 15 août les talibans à la
surprise visiblement général mais sauf à
la surprise des observateurs sérieux
rentrer dans dans kaboul donc 7,7 cette
petite séquence là c'est une opération
chimiques qui a tourné qui a tourné au
chaos et qui a failli vraiment très mal
tourner on va voir ce qui va se passer
dans l'année dans la suite mais
l'attentât il ya trois jours a montré
que les américains déjà là des gens
payent le prix ça c'est à un mois et
demi deux séquences maintenant si on
revient sur cette séquence qui ferment
en réalité une grande séquence de 20 en
2001 ambassadeur là monsieur ambassador
l'aladi 2021 les américains ont voulu
quand en 2001 les américains décident
d'aller en à kaboul les russes frappe à
la porte des américains à 10 ans vous
savez nous on n'y a été il ya passé
aussi de 1978 à 1989 ça nous a coûté à
l'époque de mémoire 26 mille morts
plusieurs centaines de mille blessés et
on sait ce qu'on peut faire pas faire et
les pièges qu'ils sont et les américains
ont dit nous avons le droit pour nous
nous avons été attaqués nous avons la
supériorité pour nous et donc pardon
désolé on va se débrouiller tout seul et
en réalité quand on regarde quand on
fait un petit peu le bilan des deux
interventions presque vingt ans pour les
russes et 20 ans aujourd'hui par les
américains on a le sentiment que les
américains ont largement plus perdus que
les russes je prendre un seul exemple
pour dieter en 80 1989 quand les russes
quittent afghanistan ils le font dans
l'ordre ça va durer quelques mois ils
rapatrient dix mille hommes 500 chars de
combat par la route et par les airs il
laisse sur place le gouvernement n'agit
lula qui est un gouvernement ami et qui
va tenir jusqu'en 1991 92 à la chute de
l'union soviétique de michail gorbatchev
a à moscou il c'est à partir de ce
moment là qu à nouveau la guerre civile
va arriver et qu'il faudra 30 1996 pour
que les talibans prennent le pouvoir à
kaboul le plus d'auditeurs l'ont bien
compris aujourd'hui un mois et demi pour
que les talibans prennent le pouvoir et
pour reprendre une expression de patrice
franceschi qui atteint qui connaît très
bien en afghanistan qui est un
aventurier carney qui a travaillé aux
côtés des résistants afghans pendant la
période soviétique en 1900 en 2010 ils
me disaient les américains ont fait pire
que les que les sommes que les
soviétiques à l'époque ils ont réussi à
transformer cette grande zone régionale
en une poudrière anti-occidental voilà
ce qui aujourd'hui menace peut-être de à
nouveau prendre corps dans les mois et
les années qui viennent même si
l'histoire ne se répète jamais
exactement justement pour faire écho à
ce que vous venez de dire à une
poudrière occidentales ont pris
d'ailleurs anti-occidentale pardon une
compris pour les états unis écoutez les
réactions de l'insee g un sénateur les
républicains en caroline du nord le
défilé des horreurs est sur le point de
se dérouler nous laissons berne où des
milliers d'afghans qui ont combattu
courageusement avec nous allons laisser
des centaines de citoyens américains le
risque d'un autre en septembre vient de
grimper en flèche je n'ai jamais été
aussi inquiet d'une attaque notre patrie
qu'en ce moment nous n'avons pas mis fin
à cette guerre elle est blanche maison
les américains qui risque tout comme
nous en france au royaume uni en europe
qui risque d'en payer le prix de cette
débâcle de ce retrait rapide des états
unis sur notre propre sol vous y croyez
alors les américains a certainement
comme ça vient d'être dit mais leur part
parce que d'actuellement le leadership
américain en prend un coup c'est fait
c'est évidemment une débâcle sur le plan
politique et sur un centre de joe dante
sur le plan militaire mais qui était
programmé qui était prévu qu'ils étaient
prévus à l'avance alors évidemment les
américains ont rapatriés
beaucoup d'afghans qui ont travaillé
avec avec eux les français ont fait la
même chose pour les vagues ont travaillé
avec eux les autres ce membre de la
coalition également mais il en reste
beaucoup et il en reste quelques
dizaines de milliers avec les familles
qui pensent que les pales les talibans
pourront les mettre à mal puisque les
talibans on le sait maintenant on des
killing liste et font du porte à porte
pour savoir où sont les gens qui ont
joué un rôle important avec le régime
précédent donc les opinions publiques
aux états unis et en europe demandent
des comptes aux dirigeants et pourquoi
vous vous laissez tomber tous ces gens
qui ont travaillé avec nous qui ont
travaillé avec nos troupes d'un autre
côté les mêmes disent on ne veut pas
d'afflux de réfugiés donc c'est un peu
la difficulté dans laquelle se trouvent
tous nos gouvernements de jouer sur les
sur les 2 sur les deux registres et
c'est pour ça que dans le fond la
proposition qui est faite au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu de créer une série
zone pourrait permettre de continuer à
aix filtrer un certain nombre d'afghans
qui ont coopéré avec le régime précédent
et avec les alliés peut-être aussi
d'ailleurs des européens des actions tôt
parce qu'il en reste il ya bien entendu
quelques journalistes qui sont encore là
on envoyait encore tout à l'heure sur
les écrans et puis des gens qui sont
dans les ong qui n'ont pas voulu partir
qui ont voulu rester sur place des
médecins sans frontières des gens comme
ça qui ont voulu rester sur place et si
ça tourne mal il faudra bien les
exfiltrer un jour d'où l'intérêt le
double intérêt de cette zone qui
peut-être sera créé 7 me peut-être pas
parce que les talibans sont aussi
divisés entre eux il ya des débats est
évidemment le mollah baradar que l'on
voit sur toutes les télévisions veut
être la branche modérée alors que le
cherche suprême des talibans que l'on ne
voit pas à la télévision tournent au
mans et bien lui à des émotions beaucoup
plus dures et veut qu'il n'y ait plus
tôt mme étrangères avant de former le
nouveau gouvernement mail avec raffray
sur la question des réfugiés on se
demande parfois évacués par les états
unis 1 on comprend que les américains
voilà les avions partent pas d'ailleurs
tout comme l' europe 1 il s'arrête à
bout des biocides sont pas des vols
directs on
comprend bien ça s'arrête en bulgarie ce
d'ailleurs mme emmanuel macron a fait
comprendre à joe biden la queue il
fallait prendre ses responsabilités
l'arrière pensée américaine c'est quoi
un accueil très limité c'est l'europe
qui qui gère en battant le cynisme les
américains ont une certaine expérience
j'irai même peut-être jusqu'à dire
qu'ils sont presque champion du monde on
vient d'apprendre via d'ailleurs le quai
d'orsay
et par des confidences of distiller
auprès de journalistes que les vols
américains de réfugiés s'arrête en
particulier en afrique on cite le rwanda
il s'arrête en europe balkany qu'on cite
l'albanie donc on voit bien que les
américains en réalité ne prendront
jamais la totalité des gens qu'ils ont
évacué en revanche les ce qui doit qui
vont devoir gérer ensuite cet afflux de
réfugiés comme l'a dit monsieur
l'ambassadeur ce sont les européens qui
sont à nouveau sur la brèche donc c'est
aussi la conséquence j'aurai terminé par
là quand même case que c'est la
conséquence d'une europe qui a trop
souvent fait preuve de nos stratégies et
en en matière de stratégie elle s'est
alignée sur la stratégie américaine et
donc elles n'ont pas l on paye
effectivement aujourd'hui le prix merci
claude blanchemaison merci également à
mériadeck afin d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce décryptage ce soir merci à vous
deux
et autres pays sous tension le yémen où
une attaque hier a fait une trentaine de
morts et plus d'une cinquantaine de
blessés la cible une base aérienne près
de la ville d'aden capitale provisoire
du gouvernement yéménite un attentat non
revendiqué que les forces militaires
loyalistes impute aux rebelles houthi et
les masquelier
les ambulances se pressent à l'entrée de
l'hôpital ibn khaldoun de la juge les
soignants prennent en charge les
dizaines de combattants blessés qui se
trouvaient sur la base aérienne surpris
un peu plus tôt par cette attaque
meurtrière
nous étions rassemblés à l'intérieur du
hangar après le petit déjeuner nous
avons vu un drone en vol stationnaire et
nous avons essayé de tirer dessus pour
la battre mais nous n'avons pas réussi à
le toucher l'engin a survolé et s'est
dirigé directement vers le hangar où il
a tiré deux missiles sur la première
unité
une explosion s'est produite à la nahd
les deux premiers missiles ont touché la
caserne il y avait plus de 50 personnes
à l'intérieur après 20 minutes un
troisième missile a touché la base
[Musique]
après 20 minutes un troisième missile a
touché la base puis environ 20 minutes
plus tard des drones sont arrivés mais
nous avons pu en toucher 1 beaucoup de
gens ont été tués et blessés
à moins de 60 km la ville d'aden
capitale provisoire du gouvernement
yéménite
s'il attaque n'a pas été revendiquée
les forces militaires loyalistes elle
pointe directement du doigt les rebelles
houthi soutenu par l'iran dans le pays
de violents affrontements ont repris
depuis près de six mois
les combats font rage dans la province
de marib dernier bastion des forces
fidèles au président abd rabbo mansour
hadi au nord du yémen
la coalition militaire dirigée par
l'arabie saoudite qui appuie le
gouvernement depuis 2015 multiplient les
raids contre les rebelles les nations
unies de leur côté ont averti que
l'offensive sur mme halib pourrait
entraîner une catastrophe humanitaire
majeure mais la récente proposition de
paix de l'onu visant à mettre fin à la
guerre a été publiquement rejeté par le
groupe outils
les parties n'ont pas encore surmonté
leurs divergences alors que le groupe
outils insiste sur un accord distinct
concernant l'utilisation des ports et
les aéroports comme condition préalable
à un cessez le feu à l'entâme d'un
processus politique
le gouvernement yéménite insiste sur la
mise en oeuvre de toutes les mesures
comme un ensemble incluant le début d'un
cessez le feu
tout comme son prédécesseur l'émissaire
de l'onu a mis fin à ces trois ans de
mission dans le pays c'est le diplomate
suédois hans kronberg qui prendra le
relais dès le 5 septembre la tâche
s'annonce compliquée
les négociations sont au point mort seul
signe de détente plusieurs rencontres
discrètes qui ont eu lieu depuis janvier
entre l'arabie saoudite et l'iran qui
n'ont plus de relations diplomatiques
depuis 2016 david michôd
en france à présent le pass sanitaire
devient obligatoire dès aujourd'hui pour
les employés des structures accueillant
du public
près de deux millions de personnes
concernées comme les restaurants les
transports publics les grands magasins
ou encore les salles de sport si le
gouvernement annonce une semaine de
souplesse les protestations contre le
passé ni terre se poursuivre les
précisions de notre reporter david
khalifa
très bon soir david vous êtes
actuellement rue montorgueil un quartier
prisé pour qui connaît paris et de
nombreux d'ailleurs touristes pour ses
restaurants et bars notamment les saints
l'arrière david de ces établissements
qui doivent désormais montrer eux aussi
patte blanche pour pouvoir travailler
une situation évidemment on imagine
compliqué à gérer
une situation compliquée à gérer pour
les salariés mais aussi pour les
restaurateurs ce nouveau cap franchi par
le passé ni terre qui concerne désormais
un million huit cent mille salariés en
france est un véritable casse tête pour
eux pour plusieurs raisons tout d'abord
car le personnel va forcément manquer de
nombreux salariés refusent de se
soumettre à l'extension de ce pass
sanitaires et préfère poser des rtt
jusqu'au 15 novembre date butoir
décidées par le gouvernement de la faim
à de cette obligation au pire encore ils
préfèrent à démissionner là encore ces
conséquences sont non négligeables pour
les restaurateurs qui sont bien souvent
pris de court autre problème certains
restaurateurs refusent d'imposer à leurs
salariés de se faire vacciner ou bien
tout simplement à tester je vous propose
d'écouter régis fay chef du restaurant
le mr est à paris
mal comme vous disiez c'est encore une
goutte d'eau
en plus encore qu'on fasse des efforts
quand vous disiez où l'eau depuis le
démarrage de cette épidémie d'avancé on
est les dindons de la farce c'est
honteux le restaurateur ça nous a
imposée très rapidement on aurait bien
avoir un mois supplémentaire pour avoir
ce pass vaccinale le problème c'est
qu'on peut pas imposer aux gens de se
faire vacciner ça on ne peut pas
les états leur les anti vaccins s'ils
veulent pas ils vont perdre leur emploi
et ce que je vous disais on va perdre
des compétences des gens professionnels
et à l'heure actuelle c'est important
parce qu'en restauration recherche du
personnel donc ça va nous faire encore
une perte à savoir que si l'employeur
refuse de contrôler à le pass and i ter
de ses employés il risque une fermeture
administrative de sept jours et en cas
de récidive il peut écoper d'une amende
de 9000 euros les salariés eux dépourvus
un des précieux sésames pourront hormis
prendre des rtt télétravail et être
affectées à postes ne nécessitant pas de
passes sanitaires ou être suspendu sans
solde en clair cela signifie la
suspension de son contrat de travail et
david une sanction qui scandalise
littéralement certains syndicats
le mot est bien choisi et stéphanie la
cgt dénonce une sanction totalement
inédite et disproportionné le syndicat
sud commerce va plus grand et appellent
à une grève illimitée à partir de ce
lundi il craint à des suspensions de
contrats et des licenciements à tout va
la sécurité de l'emploi est en danger
écoutez nous on est résolument contre
déjà parce qu'il ya des vraies
conséquences qui sont très dangereuses
pour les salariés ils peuvent se
retrouver sans salaire puis possiblement
sans emploi donc on se bat pour mac pour
montrer vraiment notre désapprobation de
ce système là et surtout les dangers qu
implique l'application du pass à
lithaire dans ces entreprises
aujourd'hui les salariés devraient avoir
le choix entre se faire vacciner ou
passer des tests pcr c'est en tout cas
la loi et pourtant la direction va au
delà de ça et ce qui arrive c'est que
des salariés sont sanctionnés de
quelques minutes de retard parce que il
ya beaucoup de files d'attentes pour
ceux qui n'ont pas le couple phil et le
copil c'est donner votre calendrier
vaccinal des informations normalement
crête normalement confidentielles que
vous n'avez pas donné votre employeur
mais votre employeur vous demande de les
donner si vous voulez arriver plus vite
ça va être encore compris l'inquiétude
est de mise notamment sur les problèmes
de logistique comme aux galeries
lafayette à paris ce qui rejoint d'une
certaine manière cet esprit de
contestation générale contre le passait
sanitaire considérée comme liberticide
pour la plupart de ces syndicats alors
évidemment tous ne sont pas du même avis
d'autres préfèrent se soumettre à
l'extension de ce pass sanitaire plutôt
que de subir une nouvelle fermeture mais
là encore le débat est ouvert merci
david débat à suivre surtout merci david
qualif en direct donc de la rue de
monthoux org et on le disait un
manifestation anti pas sanitaire dans
200 villes de france en ce samedi encore
mais aussi la justice qui se met en
travers de sa route après les yvelines
et le haut rhin la justice qui a à
nouveau trancher dans l'essonne ce
week-end contre le gouvernement et
tribunaux administratifs suspende jour
après jour des arrêtés préfectoraux
concernant l'obligation de se passe dans
les grands centres commerciaux nadège
abderrazak nous sommes devant le centre
commercial vélizy 2 à vélizy
villacoublay dans les yvelines s'il n'y
a pas foule derrière moi au centre de
dépistage antico vide c'est parce que
depuis quelques jours il n'est plus
obligatoire de présenter un pass
sanitaires pour accéder au centre
commercial et décision du tribunal
administratif de versailles qui a
suspendu l'arrêté préfectoral concernant
l'obligation du passani terre dans les
grands centres commerciaux décision de
justice similaire dans l'essonne et le
haut rhin selon la justice s'est arrêté
ne permettent pas en effet de garantir
un accès libre aux biens de première
nécessité
les mesures de restrictions imposées par
le préfet du haut-rhin s'applique de
façon générale et absolue à l'ensemble
des commerces situés dans les grands
magasins et centres commerciaux liste et
elle ne prévoit aucun aménagement
permettant de réserver l'accès des
personnes ne disposant pas de passes
sanitaires aux établissements
commercialisant des biens de première
nécessité dans l'enceinte de ses
magasins et centres en particulier aux
commerces alimentaires
en seine-saint-denis 12 centres
commerciaux sont concernées par
l'obligation du pass sanitaires à
l'entrée quatre particulier chez le
syndicat cgt 93 ont saisi le tribunal
administratif de montreuil pour
contester l'arrêté préfectoral en
question ils ont pour leur part reçu une
fin de non recevoir de la part de la
justice la requête ne tenait compte ni
de la situation sanitaire ni de
l'intérêt de santé publique ni de la
lutte contre la propagation de
l'épidémie de kobe 19 ce n'est peut-être
que partie remise
après des victoires dans les yvelines et
l'essonne l'avocat tarek corail thème en
charge du dossier estime que la mesure
de suspension devrait être appliquée
partout sur le territoire il ne peut pas
y avoir une différence de traitement
entre les habitants de plusieurs
départements je vais déposer un recours
devant le tribunal administratif de
paris des suspensions en cascade
synonyme de véritable camouflet pour le
gouvernement et qui compte bien faire
appel de cette décision de justice on a
décidé de faire appel de ces décisions
parce qu'on considère que le pass
sanitaire doit continuer à s'appliquer
pour le moment dans les lieux dans
lesquels il était prévu il était aussi
prévu que le pass sanitaire
disparaissent au 15 novembre mais le
gouvernement pourrait en décider
autrement ça pourrait arriver si le coc
vide ne disparaissaient pas de nos vies
dans les trois prochains mois les
derniers réticents sont en train de
tomber face au succès du pass and i ter
faut dire qu'il ya peut-être une forme
de dénicher le ministre de la santé qui
refuse d'admettre les nombreuses
procédures judiciaires et les
manifestations massives contre le pass
sanitaires qui ont lieu chaque week end
depuis le mois de juillet et la semaine
dernière bruno le maire a annoncé la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte le ministre de
l'économie en a précisé les modalités ce
matin le fonds de solidarité dédié de
nombreux secteurs économiques depuis le
début de la pandémie disparaîtra le 30
septembre il sera remplacé par une aide
au cas par cas de prise en charge des
coûts fixes pour les entreprises des
secteurs encore touché une annonce faite
devant les représentants des filles hier
concernés restauration hôtellerie
culture ou encore tourisme
à partir du 30 septembre cette année le
fonds de solidarité sera supprimé ça
rappelle que les chiffres sont aussi
très clair il y avait cinq cent mille
demandes de indemnisations tiré du fonds
de solidarité en mai dernier on est
passé à 50 milles au mois de juillet
soit 10 fois moins tout simplement parce
que le retour à la normale se marquent
aussi dans des moindres demandes du
front de solidarité
cette transition de 1 mois pour la
disparition du fonds de solidarité
s'accompagnera d'une indemnisation à
hauteur de 20% de la perte de chiffre
d'affaires néanmoins l'intégralité des
dispositifs de soutien sera maintenue
pour les départements d'outre-mer qui
sont encore soumis à des obligations de
fermeture et pour en parler nous sommes
avec un jean ferland vice-président
humide la branche restauration bonsoir
jean t1 non merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur écran ce n'est pas sanitaire
obligatoire dès aujourd'hui donc on l'a
dit dans dans la restauration qu'est-ce
qui est mis concrètement en place pour
les salariés
pour les salariés pour les entreprises
pourront être les seuls à
l'état pour les autres pour les deux nés
de et bien écoutez le fonds de
solidarité évidemment il était prévu
qu'ils de s'amoindrit au fur et à mesure
du temps et donc comme à dix ministres
effectivement on est passé de 10 fois
moins de demande donc ça c'est bon signe
pour la restauration et l'hôtellerie
enfin surtout la restauration et les
cafés l'hôtellerie c'est plus compliqué
mais donc ce fonds de solidarité va être
adaptée à chaque situation et on va il
vendu faire il a donc se faire du cas
par cas et affiner des aides en fonction
de la réalité des besoins des
professionnels qui sera encore en
difficulté
quand vous échanger avec vos salariés
aujourd'hui dans quel état d'esprit sont
ils parce qu'il ya beaucoup quand même
de de pression aussi à on le voit
lorsque l'on va dans un restaurant
depuis quelques jours
non pas l'impression de se transformer
en rencontres olharan gendarmes
oui alors évidemment il ya eu beaucoup
d'inquiétudes c'est normal puisque rond
on découvrait une nouvelle fonction qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas dans nos gènes
puisqu'on est là pour l'accueil pour le
plaisir pour le sourire et non pour des
contrôles sanitaires donc il a fallu
s'adapter et mettre en place le pass
sanitaires techniquement globalement ça
s'est très bien passé il ya quelques cas
très très
petit nombre qui ont refusé certaines
choses mais globalement ça s'est
globalement bien passée les français
l'ont accepté les les entreprises ont
mis avant d'appliquer tout simplement la
loi parce qu on est dans l'obligation
d'appliquer la loi maintenant
aujourd'hui on a en plus le contrôle des
salariés et plus de 80% des salariés
étaient à weiler pas s'énerver
vaccination ou un test pcr donc que 10
rebonds norman ans on va dire que les
choses se passent pas si mal que ça et
avec un état qui va continuer à
surveiller et à aider le plus possible
ceux qui sont en grande difficulté
reprenons les choses dans l'ordre tout
d'abord cette confusion de départ les
salariés quand il refuse justement se
passa ni terre quelle est l'attitude que
doit adopter l'entreprise est ce que
vous êtes accompagné sur ce point parce
qu'on veut bien appliquer la loi mais
enfin il faut tout de même être
accompagné puisque une fois encore ce
n'est pas votre coeur de métier le
contrôle non bien sûr que c'est
difficile ça ça crée des relations ça va
créer une relation très compliqué pour
des personnes qui sont anti vaccins
majoritairement c'est surtout là qu'il
peut y avoir des tensions il y à il ya
des solutions intermédiaires avant de
passer vraiment à la solution radicale
qui est de se séparer d'un salarié ce
qui est quand même un peu difficile ça
peut éventuellement aller jusque là mais
je pense qu'on arrivera pas jusque là je
pense que tout le monde la sait qu'il
faut pour garder son emploi et pour pour
que ça se passe bien faire en sorte
d'avoir un d'avoir une vaccination
complète et son pass sanitaire donc il
ya des mesures intermédiaire avant qui
sont de prendre des congés qui sont
prendre dé prendre des rtt c'est sûr que
c'est pas facile à appliquer dans un
secteur où il manque de salariés où il
manque de personnel surtout en salle sa
peine c'est là la faisabilité de
suspendre quelqu'un soit de le mettre en
vacances l'admettre dans un autre poste
parce que les postes dans la
restauration sont pas interchangeables
soit vous êtes en salsa vous êtes en
cuisine on peut pas mettre un serveur en
cuisine sous prétexte que il n'a pas
s'en passe donc ça bouscule complètement
le fonctionnement du durée ce temps
messi à plus de 80% les personnels à son
pass annie terre je pense que les choses
vont se régler j'espère et est ce que
j'entends et ce que je vois de mes
collègues et nous mêmes il ya des choses
se passent assez assez
assez sympathique m'en venir est-ce que
ça se passe aussi sympathique mais on a
commencé à en parler tout à l'heure à
l'entrée des restaurants vous nous
disiez oui dans la majorité des cas mais
est ce que ces personnels sont formés
devant des refus on a vu qu'il ya
beaucoup de colère dans le pays beaucoup
d'incompréhension il ya des
manifestations anti passe sanitaire tous
les week-ends 200 villes de france
encore ce week-end quelle est l'attitude
à adopter
là encore est ce que ces salariés sont
sont accompagnés pour avoir la marche à
suivre
bien sûr ne sommes pas désunis nos
serveurs ne sont pas des agents de
sécurité nous sommes nous mêmes par des
agents de sécurité dans un monde idéal
il aurait été formidable d'avoir une
personne dédiée à cette fonction qui
aurait pour le client une respectabilité
plus plus imposant que de quelqu'un du
personnel de la salle où même le chef
d'entreprise mais bon comme on n'a pas
les moyens ni ni la possibilité de dans
l'est surtout dans des petites
structures les grandes structures de
restauration ont pu
utiliser des agents de sécurité qui est
pour eux beaucoup plus facile d'imposer
le pass mais on a on a vu que je veux
dire les français ont mal en restaurant
il savait avec toute la communication et
l'information vous avez tous donné que
pour aller restants il fallait un pass
sanitaire donc on a affaire à quelques
reprises quelques personnes qui sont au
vaccin les manifestations certes elles
ont lieu mais comparé au nombre de
personnes vaccinées et nombre de
personnes dans les rues c'est sûr que
peut-être que c'est un peu
disproportionnée la la teneur dans
laquelle on les met aujourd'hui donc
nous pour l'instant on a on a eu un ou
deux cas en france dans la restauration
où il ya eu des contrôles un peu un peu
un peu moins moins sympathique serait dû
se passer mais je veux dire deux trois
cadres la france entière c'est quand
même pas énorme donc on va pour une fois
je vais est assez optimiste est allé un
peu de l'avant et en se disant que en
espérant que le 15 novembre
remettent le fonctionnement d'un
restaurant dans un état normal et
conviennent au restaurant non pas pour
se faire contrôler mais pour passer un
bon moment je pense que c'est ce qu'il
faut espérer que le taux de vaccination
barry dassin justement la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte
un protocole sanitaire quand même de
contraignant vous avez joué le jeu a
pour beaucoup de restaurants dont se
passe sanitaire
mais tout de même ce variant delta qui
continue à nous embêter d'avis et si
j'ose dire vous êtes optimiste vous sûr
sûr sûr l'avenir clairement bas je ne
suis pas médecin je suis cuisinier jeu
j'essaie de
c'est un métier c'est un métier où il
faut s'adapter tous les matins quand on
ouvre notre restaurant donc il a pu
s'adapter on est habitué à s'adapter par
un modifié mais s'adapter donc on espère
qu effectivement par rapport à tout ce
que l'on nous explique on devrait
arriver à ce que
le 15 novembre ont soit débarrassé vente
est vendu pas sanitaires pourraient dans
les restaurants en sachant quand même
que un restaurant n'est pas un lieu de
contamination
ça n'a jamais été démontrée puisque le
malheureusement le virus s'est
développée lorsqu'on était fermée donc
on sait tout le monde sait que c'est
dans l'est dans les regroupements
familiaux dans l'est réunion privée où
les gens pris aucune consigne de
sécurité pas de port du masque de se
laver les mains fin personne pour les
contraindre à avoir un minimum de
sécurité sanitaire ou les ou les virus à
circuler donc nos établissements depuis
la 1er déconfinement et la première
ouverture ont mis des protocoles
sanitaires drastiques et appliquée dans
les restaurants on est des gens
professionnels responsables on a tout
intérêt à ce que ça se passe bien afin
que les français les clients en général
sache que d'aller dans un restaurant
c'est pas un endroit dangereux bien au
contraire mais si jean terlon d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
en israël à présent la troisième
injection tiko vide est désormais
ouverte à tous ou presque les enfants
j'ai de 12 ans minimum peuvent recevoir
une dose de rappel annonce hier du
gouvernement israélien pour tenter de
lutter contre la flambée de nouveaux cas
reliés aux variants delta l état hébreu
qui a lancé une campagne au milieu de
l'été pour que les plus de 60 ans
reçoivent une troisième fois le sérum
du corps sauter manque d'âme je veux en
finir le plus vite possible retrouver
une vraie vi pour qu'il n'y ait pas un
autre confinement ce qui serait un peu
inquiétant plus que le vaccin
je me fiche de ce qu'on dit sur le
vaccin ces effets secondaires et tout le
reste les deux dernières injections que
j'ai reçu ce mot aucun effet secondaire
[Musique]
je suis arrivé rapidement je pense que
tout le monde devrait se faire vacciner
je me suis inscrite ir et c'est tout je
pense que cela va nous aider à surmonter
cette horrible pandémie c'est tout
faites vous vacciner
nous parlons d'une très grande adhérence
de la population et nous espérons que
dans les jours à venir nous verrons de
plus en plus de personnes se faire
vacciner nous pensons que si
suffisamment de personnes se font
vacciner contre le coc vide dans toutes
les tranches d'âge
nous pourrons gérer cette quatrième
vague et nous pourrons ramener le pays à
la vie que nous connaissions avant le
début de la vague delta we knew too big
n et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis tel aviv en israël avec
jaws brienne médecin spécialiste des
maladies infectieuses c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir josiane merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france selon
l'organisme de santé la troisième dose
et efficace à 86% contre les infections
chez les plus de 60 ans cela montre que
qu'une troisième tome sera obligatoire
pour pour l'ensemble de la population
pour lutter contre les variants en gros
il va falloir se faire vacciner tous les
six mois
attendue
j'aimerais pouvoir rythmique vous
réponds mais je ne lis pas dans les
boules de cristal et aujourd'hui ce que
l'on sait c'est que la 3e 2 et efficace
à plus de 86% 80% à la fin de la
première semaine et 95 94 % après deux
semaines pourquoi avons nous proposer
cette 3e 2 c'est là c'est la question
qu'il faut se poser nous avons constaté
qu'au bout de quelques mois il y avait
une diminution de l'immunité
après les deux premiers vaccins et ce
troisième vaccin et comment de booster
ça permet de faire remonter l'immunité
et de se retrouver ainsi dans une
production maximale
qu'en est il de ce qui se passera dans
quelques mois nul ne le sait nous
espérons que ce booster permettra de
faire durer longtemps cette
sécurité nous ne sommes pas sur notre
cas pour quelques mois nous en sommes à
peu près certain après personne ne le
sait tout de contrôler la forme
pourquoi je lis ton parce qu'évidemment
vous vous le savez il ya de nombreuses
personnes réfractaires encore et
toujours au vaccin qu'est ce qu'on peut
leur dire parce que depuis le début ces
derniers nous disent voilà on va nous
demander de nous faire vacciner tous les
six mois ils voient ça d'un très mauvais
oeil
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez
justement pour les convaincre que ne
serait-ce que déjà de la première dose
pour certains mais la troisième dose est
ce que ça ne fait pas beaucoup
ça fait certainement beaucoup bien sûr
mais comparativement aux dégâts que
cause la qu'ovide je n'ai pas d'autres
arguments que dehors demandé de faire
attention à leur vue aujourd'hui il ya
plus de cinq millions et demi de morts
dans le monde avec un vaccin l'imaginer
sans vaccin ce cas c'est ce que ce
serait on a au début
certains comparent et l'aco vida à une
sorte de grippette mais vous savez la
grippe malgré le vaccin annuel fait 300
400 mille morceaux qui est énorme ici
nous sommes à plus de cinq millions et
demi de morts il n'ya pas d'autre de
d'autres formes de
d'arguments et puis vous savez le
couvent il savait pas une simple petite
maladie c'est quelque chose qui entraîne
des effets secondaires sérieux moi j'en
vois tous les jours je voit tous les
jours des gens qui ont eu le qu'ovide et
qui sait qu'ils ont des qui garde encore
des manifestations extrêmement pénible
donc outre outre la mort que cela
entraîne ça entraîne aussi un certain
nombre de problèmes qui sont ce qu'on
appelle les copies de l'an mais
également un certain nombre d'autres
problèmes de santé qui dure qui dure et
qui empoisonnent la vie des gens c'est
vraiment le seul argument cession des
arguments de médecins que je vous donne
je n'ai pas d'autres arguments bien sûr
il serait la
dose vacciner pardon de doses 1 58% de
la population pourtant
l'état hébreu était réputé pour être
champion de la vaccination au début de
cette campagne pourquoi ça s'est ensuite
taris a ralenti pour quelles raisons
l'écouté nous avons à ce jour
six millions de personnes qui ont reçu
une première deux et cinq millions et
demi de personnes qui ont reçu 2 2 et
pour compléter plus de deux millions de
personnes ont reçu la troisième 2 donc
il ya une augmentation qui se fait
lentement mais qui se fait nous avons un
problème aussi aujourd'hui avec comme
dans tous les pays du monde avec un
certain nombre de personnes qui ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner nous avons
un peu moins d'un million de personnes
qui ne ne sont pas vaccinés actuellement
un million de personnes ou un peu moins
sur neuf millions 9 mois et demi ça fait
quand même un certain pourcentage ce qui
explique qu' il y a eu une recrudescence
donc 2 2 2 de l'aco vide avec son son
variant delta d'où aujourd'hui les
incitations les fortes incitations à se
faire vacciner pour 1ère 2e 2 mégas
l'encontre la troisième avec un 3e 2 et
vous voyez il y a un fort engouement en
israël pour cette 3e 2 puisque nous
sommes aujourd'hui à plus de 2 millions
d'israéliens qui ont reçu 7 et 3 2 nous
espérons ainsi que ce rappel vaccinal
portera ses fruits davidsen de porter
ses fruits déjà d'ailleurs et il a
permis une baisse certaine
décontamination et après ce qui a été un
regain virulent au moins deux joueurs en
fait nous espérions avoir atteint une
sorte d'immunité collective en mai avril
mais mai manimal malheureusement c'est
pas été le cas d'où aujourd'hui cette
proposition de 3e de rapidement très
rapidement doctorales et les enfants de
plus de 12 ans sont concernés notamment
par cette troisième dos c'est une bonne
chose pour pour vous alors qu'ils ne
sont pas nécessairement à risque
écoutez le problème est le suivant si
vous comptez 100 personnes qui ont le
pion de l'aco vide sur 100 personnes
vous avez 50 qui sont des enfants les
enfants heureusement ne sont pas
gravement atteints mais ils sont
extrêmement contagieux ils sont
contaminés et contaminant et donc pour
l'ensemble de la population pour pour
leurs parents leurs grands parents pour
qu'ils puissent vivre normalement
la proposition de de ce vaccin leur a
été faite élise y ont adhéré 1
globalement nous avons des chiffres
importants de près de 65 à 70 % de
jeunes qui ont qui ont décidé de se
faire vacciner il n'y a vraiment aucune
contrainte en israël c'est vraiment
d'une démarche volontariste et et cela
permet peut-être va pas permettre comme
ça de passer cet
cette vague qui arrive est de pouvoir à
peu près vivre
pas comme avant mais
merci en tout cas de l'oise aisne
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
france pourvu d'extérieur ce soir restez
avec nous dans quelques instants
primaire ou pas primaire à huit mois de
l'élection présidentielle c'est la même
question qui se pose à droite comme à
gauche nous en parlerons dans notre face
à face et puis nous évoquons les
élections législatives en allemagne où
la course à la succession de la
chancelière merkel s'intensifie
[Musique]
vous
parce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république en haïti
l'état de droit a été véritablement mise
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode de crapuleux on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort duquel il
est clair pour tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
je
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe islamisme radical de
la saur c'est l'élite des renseignements
généraux de la police française c'était
après les attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service vous ne pouvez absolument pas
refusé votre mission première est celle
de traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que je sors mon arme tout est passé dans
ma tête est ce que vous avez appris de
ces profils qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
chercher d'ailleurs dans la religion le
profil vient toujours de la misère
sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation il faut que
nous reprenions la place dans le cerveau
des enfants et de la jeunesse
[Musique]
la fed pourrait bien se fermer le
robinet la majorité de ses membres se
disent favorables au top twin une
réduction des achats d'actifs
aujourd'hui on est dans quelque chose
qui ne peut pas être modifiée vous êtes
obligés d'en remettre à chaque fois un
petit peu plus l'économie réelle est le
suis pas donc c'est le moment de
communiquer rosso modo de faire
comprendre à tout le monde dont cette
politique elle pose des problèmes on est
en train de mettre l'économie réelle à
risque on la soumet vraiment un risque
important les banques centrales
aujourd'hui son market dépendantes et
uniquement martel l'époque donc si elles
ne veulent pas aujourd'hui réduire leurs
achats c'est tout simplement parce que
elles savent très bien que le jour où
elle annonce seront réellement une
réduction de leurs achats les marchés
vont s'effondrer
[Musique]
mais 21h bonsoir à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième partie
d'émission au sommaire à 21 heures la
crise sanitaire aura-t-elle un impact
sur la campagne présidentielle qui
s'annonce déjà féroce le compte à
rebours est lancé dans 34 semaines les
français voteront pour le prochain
président de la république
à droite la dispersion semble avoir déjà
fait ses premières victimes et se pose
évidemment la question des primaires
interrogations à gauche est également où
plusieurs personnalités se verrait bien
à la place d'emmanuel mettront
[Musique]
alors primaire opa primaire à huit mois
de la présidentielle c'est la même
question qui se pose inexorablement à
droite comme à gauche
l'organisation d'une primaire est
pourtant prévue dans les statuts de ces
deux grands partis historiques alors
peuvent-ils faire l'impasse sur cette
prédiction est désigné sans débat leur
candidat c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric sinclair éditorialiste qui est
en direct avec nous par skype vous avez
été l'un des conseillers politiques de
dominique de villepin quand il était
premier ministre bonsoir frédéric 5r
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau en
studio alexis poulain qu'on connaît très
bien ici notre éditorialiste bonsoir
alexis xavier bertrand dont valérie
pécresse philippe juvin michèle bernier
ou encore david lisnard ça fait du monde
déjà à droite les candidats sortent du
bois c'est une vraie purée de pois ce
qui inquiète évidemment les ténors du
parti comme notamment le sénateur a
l'air de vendée bruno retailleau avant
de vous faire réagir messieurs je vous
propose de l'écouter
meilleur ennemi la droite c'est la
droite ce sont nos confusion nos
divisions nos confusion qui trop souvent
des routes nos électeurs nos divisions
qui les dégoûte non il faut que on
arrive à se situer et à nous hisser à
hauteur de cet enjeu en portant un vrai
projet et ce projet là ça ne peut pas
être une droite de contrition qui le
porte ça doit être une droite de
conviction
c'est lui qui a donc surpris tout le
monde c'est laurent wauquiez on en
parlera tout à l'heure clairement le
meilleur ennemi de la droite c'est la
droite frédéric saint clair vous
confirmez
historiquement oui c'est vrai
il ya il ya un ferment de
division si on regarde un tout petit peu
plus près en réalité il ya un non dit à
droite
la droite quand on revient aux années 80
c'était le rpr et l'udf
qui faisait alliance au moment des
échéances électorales et dans une
alliance on passe un contrat qu'on est
libre de respecter ou pas mais si on ne
respecte pas en rond et à ce moment là
chacun reprend ses billes il ya une
espèce de d'honnêteté intellectuelle à
dire bon bah on va essayer de travailler
ensemble et on va voir
mesure on peut le faire quand on a
fabriqué l'ump cette espèce d'énorme
machine à gagner l'élection
présidentielle
ça a été bénéfique quand il ya eu une
personnalité qui a été capable à la fois
de séduire rpr et udf mais quand elle
n'a plus été le cas c'était une machine
à perdre et on est là aujourd'hui on est
dans une machine et l'eire qui me
ressemble plus à rien parce qu'elle
coalisent des courants qui ne qui ne
regardent plus dans la même direction il
cessa en réalité qui le le vrai nom dit
tout le monde rêve encore d'un grand
l'ump aime la vérité c'est que ce dont
il a besoin à droite c'est d'un edf d'un
nouveau udf et nourrir père ça y est
alexis poulain la machine à perdre
comment on l'appelle tous les jours
c'est devenu voilà un mot du du larousse
si j'ose dire elle est lancée cette
machine à perdre parce que c'est vrai
que quand on est partisan de ce parti ça
fait un petit peu peur ben oui le
problème de la primaire que ce soit à
gauche comme à droite c'est que ces
grands partis ont sont allés un peu vite
dans un système à l'américaine pensant
que les institutions françaises la vie
politique française pouvait
s'adapter il n'en est rien on voit bien
que la question de la gestion du débat
la question d'émotion que ce soit parti
socialiste mais des courants aussi on
parlait de l'udf ou du rpr pour mettre
tous ces gens autour d'une table ça
prend beaucoup de temps et il faut
surtout éviter les caméras or une
primaire c'est un exercice de
communication de marketing politique qui
fait beaucoup de mal puisque on dit
beaucoup de choses l'idée c'est de se
démarquer d'arriver à être celui qui va
être élu et une fois les choses fait le
pire c'est qu'on a des personnalités
comme manuel valls qui s'engagent sur
parole à soutenir le candidat et qui une
fois le candidat et vu que c'est pas lui
dire vous savez je reprends ma liberté
donc ça ne peut pas fonctionner dans un
cadre où il n'ya pas de règle et où il
n'y a pas une habitude ça marche quand
on a deux les grandes hall partys les
deux partis américains qui ont cette
capacité à faire le débat en interne et
qui comprennent qu'un seul candidat peut
marcher dans ce système dit partisan en
france c'est vraiment tout autre chose
et je crois que la réflexion est en
train d'être fait en direct c'est un peu
tard pour ses parties de se dire est ce
qu'on va refaire l'erreur des primaires
où est ce qu'on va trouver une autre
façon de faire
mais aujourd'hui la question est posée
et on voit bien que personne souhaite
être le premier à y répondre parce qu'en
même temps les primaires ça permet pas
de refus de renflouer les partir
puisqu'il faut payer pour y participer
et ça permet aussi de prendre un peu de
temps médiatique et c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire quand même vous êtes
bien pessimiste messieurs parce que on
se souvient que les primaires de la
droite en 2016 à frédéric sinclair je
parle sous votre contrôle c'était quand
même plutôt un succès plus de 4 millions
de votants les finances des partis
remise à plat un candidat propulsé en
sortie des primaires on ne racontera pas
la suite évidemment pour lui avec 66 %
d'intentions de vote qu'est ce qui
coince cette fois ci
ce qui coinçait que les une grande
partie du personnel politique de droite
crois que c'est la primaire de 2016 qui
a fait l'échec de 2017
or en réalité il n'ya que françois
fillon qui portent cette responsabilité
quand jeudi françois fillon
bien comprendre qu' il n'était pas tout
seul à porter la responsabilité il ya le
pnf qui a été père a pu enfin on connaît
l'histoire j'ai pas vouloir faire il ya
eu une dénonciation il ya tout un tas de
trucs et le robert bourgi qui est venu
faire le clown à l'antenne donc il y
avait là il ya eu toute une tout a tout
eu tout un cadre qui acquit qui s'est
effondré sous les pieds de la droite et
puis des défections valérie pécresse
xavier bertrand christian estrosi ont
été les premiers à planter des couteaux
dans le dos de françois fillon dont les
premiers à déserter d'ailleurs de l'e3
ont quitté le parti aujourd'hui donc
fondamentalement c'est ça qui a qui a
qui a effondrée la droite or on la tribu
en réalité à la primaire qui vous l'avez
dit et c'était assez justes a été un
grand moment de télévision et finalement
quelque chose de plutôt positif parce
qu'on a vu émerger une figure françois
fillon qu'on attendait pas du tout au
début on pensait que juppé serait
vainqueur en réalité nicolas sarkozy
était sur le retour et puis n'a pas pu
concourir au deuxième tour donc
fondamentalement c'était plutôt une
bonne surprise il aurait pu arriver dans
cette primaire là avec la même espérance
et se dire bon on va faire quelque chose
d'un peu punk si on va occuper l'espace
médiatique pendant tout l'automne c'est
pas du tout le cas il joue petit bras et
en jouant petit bras avec des primaires
comme ça ça coûte cher et on se plante
oui on se plante est en tout cas
certains ne veulent même pas se mouiller
et laurent vaud il a surpris tout le
monde je le disais tout à l'heure
l'ancien président des républicains
actuel patron de la région rhône-alpes a
renoncé à sa candidature je vous propose
justement d'écouter ses raisons
aucun candidat ne s'impose à droite et
personne n'a la force et la légitimité
pour imposer sa candidature comme de
gaulle pompidou où sarkozy ont pu le
faire je vois les candidatures à droite
se multipliaient dangereusement sans
même que l'on sache comment elles seront
départagées et je vois les dangers que
font peser les aventures solitaires sur
nos chances de victoire un petit pic
alexis pour la à xavier bertrand qui
refuse pas de passer par la case
primaire ben évidemment mais mais encore
une fois on a affaire à des candidats
qui ne sont pas membres pas encarté au
parti qui va organiser les primaires
donc ces primaires de la droite et du
centre elles sont déjà à handicap en
réalité un parti peut faire des
primaires avec des gens qui sont au sein
du parti il faut d'abord un intérêt
commun il faut des idées communes une
plate forme programmatique à la base or
là on voit bien que c'est une affaire
d'ego c'est une affaire de marketing
politique il suffit d'écouter valérie
pécresse qui à longueur de plateau
explique qu'elle est là pour les
nouvelles idées le renouveau et qui fait
finalement dudu reçu cette idée de
françois fillon et d'autres depuis des
années vous avez bertrand qui essaye de
jouer la carte à la hollande du du
candidat normal le français moyen qui va
essayer de réconcilier ce pays mais
pareil on attend de voir quelle va être
qu'elle va être perdant son programme
donc on est vraiment dans un exercice de
communication politique qui dessert le
jeu des idées du débat politique qui
demande plus de temps qui demandent plus
d'implication aussi qui demande plus de
travail de la part des militants mais
aussi de ces personnes qui vont ensuite
incarné ses idées donc on a l'impression
que c'est un peu le le prêt-à-penser il
faut aller vite et puis il faut dire
vous savez l'idée c'est d'être face à
emmanuel macron donc je vais essayer
d'être tout sauf mme emmanuel macron
d'une certaine façon et reprendre
quelques grands poncifs alors le
gaullisme évidemment même si beaucoup ne
savent plus ce que ça veut dire ou bien
le néolibéralisme libéralisme la social
démocratie à la thatcher ou à la merkel
on a vu ce que disait valérie pécresse
et xavier bertrand qui également se met
dans la suite des malades macron d'une
certaine façon en remettant le local au
coeur au coeur du débat mais rien de
neuf finalement sous ce clocher la de la
primaire alors avant d'aborder le cas de
la gauche pour finir sur sur la droite
fredericks à clary la raison alors en
vue de créer quand il dit aujourd'hui
personne n'a la légitimité de s'imposer
comme un sarkozy ou comme un de gaulle
bon xavier bertrand tient la corde quand
même dans les sondages il a brillamment
réussi c'est ces élections locales il
n'a pas cette légitimité clairement
alors non il n'a pas le brillamment
réussi on pourrait on pourrait y revenir
on l'a longuement fait pendant les
régionales il est élu avec la moitié des
voix de la fois d'avant en 2015 donc en
réalité il ait eue avec un million
quatre de vous en 2015 avec 700 milles
seulement en
2021 en 2020 dockers en réalité un
affaiblissement mais comme il ya une
abstention énorme on a l'impression que
les secours progressent mais mais mais
c'est pas le cas en réalité l abstention
a fait beaucoup de mal à tout le monde
il a joué avec une forte communication à
ce moment là il s'est placé tout seul
dans sa force en réalité c'est de
générer l'air c'est à dire de faire peur
à l air et de dire je vais y aller tout
seul malgré tout et j'ai le moyen de
vous faire très mal et comme l air n'est
pas en position de force eh bien elle
sait qu'elle n'a aucun candidat cette
formation politique qui puisse
supplanter écrasé xavier bertrand en
réalité le vrai travail que devrait
faire aujourd'hui les dirigeants de l
air c'est de faire une énorme campagne
de manière à légitimer le candidat qui
sortirait l ère de la primaire est de
contraindre xavier bertrand à a renoncé
mais pour ça il faut un vrai courage
politique qui n'en n'ont pas un dernier
mot quand même au niveau des proximité
idéologique il ya quand même de très
très forte proximité entre les l'air qui
ont rejoint emmanuel macron et ceux qui
ont quitté l air et qu'ils disent qu'ils
sont ni macro ni l air donc là on a
quand même aussi un espèce de brouillage
des cartes absolument incroyable on se
demande presque même comment ça se fait
que xavier bertrand n'a pas rejoint
emmanuel macron plutôt parce que la
compatibilité et entre ce gaulliste
social et le social libéral qui emmanuel
macron il quasiment totale alors à
gaussin présent ça ça coince également
en hausse mais pas trop d'accord sur
l'organisation de la primaire est ce qu
on est dans le même cas de figure que
chez les républicains allaient on
l'appelle aussi inscrite dans les
statuts du parti socialiste
clairement alexis poulain les dirigeants
peuvent en faire l'impasse là encore oui
parce que déjà à gauche c'est pas les
candidats qui manquent mais candidats
déclarés il y en a peu encore une fois
encore une fois il ya un jeu qui se fait
avec la france a soumises jean luc
mélenchon qui lui a décidé de toute
façon de faire une campagne solo en
disant ça ne sert à rien de rentrer dans
un jeu des primaires vous avez une autre
plateforme qui est la primaire populaire
qui aimeraient voir émerger une
candidature comme celle de christiane
taubira par exemple et anne hidalgo qui
se dit est ce que j'ai besoin finalement
du parti socialiste où est ce que ça
pourrait être délicat avec tous ces
couteaux qu'on va implanter dans le dos
si jamais je sors trop tôt du bois donc
on exactement dans le même principe pire
encore je crois que que chez l ère où on
peut remettre en scène à la primaire on
a vu laurent wauquiez qui lui il décide
de ne pas être candidat qui va peser
autrement sur la campagne on a vu des
ralliements aussi qu'ils commencent à se
faire à gauche on a l'impression que
c'est encore plus brouillon et que par
contre c'est cette primaire benoît hamon
était sorti vainqueur a été une vraie
catastrophe parce qu'on avait les
frondeurs d'un côté françois hollande
qui ne se présentait pas emon macron qui
a gagné en refusant de faire la primaire
à gauche alors qu'il venait du parti
socialiste est bien sûr l'attitude de
certains comme manuel valls qui ont
travaillé dès les résultats connus donc
je crois que c'est pareil à gauche là la
primaire elle est vue avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude de lassitude et se dire
c'est pas forcément le meilleur outil
pour avoir un candidat
frédéric saint clair le mot de la fin
est ce que c'est démocratique tout ça ce
qu'il ya vraiment une opposition en
ordre de marche pour reprendre certains
termes pour affronter
emmanuel macron lors de la prochaine
présidentielle selon vous une opposition
à gauche une opposition tout court parce
qu'on sait pas bien si elle est de
gauche ou droite un puisqu'on sait
parfois pas bien signé mais ne
manquerait de gauche ou droite selon les
observateurs il il est vrai que
aujourd'hui
le
caractère ambigu de cette élection
présidentielle qui s'annonce c'est que
emmanuel macron est un président qui
menait qui n'est globalement pas
apprécié même si dans les sondages il a
un peu plus haut que ses prédécesseurs
la défiance reste grande mais par contre
la fracturation de l'échiquier politique
est tel que on ne parvient pas ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre à fabriquer de
l'unité et donc à laisser espérer aux
français qui puisse y avoir une
alternance et là il ya un risque parce
que vous parliez démocratie le risque
est là à partir du moment où il ya plus
d'alternance possible ou simplement
c'est quelqu'un qui est minoritaire dans
l'opinion mais majoritaires dans les
urnes qui reprend le pouvoir d'une fois
sur l'autre et un moment si la
démocratie n'est pas capable de respirer
et d'offrir l'alternance et bien c'est
dans la rue qu'on va aller chercher la
contestation et puis ça peut fabriquer
pour le prochain quinquennat et bien des
mouvements type e j les jeunes + + où
l'insurrection ne s'arrêtera pas à la
porte de luz ouais merci frédéric cinq
heures pour cette analyse merci
également à vous alexis poulin
et autres rats à présent armin laschet
passe à l'offensive c'est l'analyse des
médias allemands au lendemain du premier
débat télévisé entre les trois candidats
à la chancellerie problème le candidat
conservateur est à la traîne dans les
sondages à un mois des élections
fédérales le social démocrate olaf
scholz devancé l'écologiste anna lena
barbeuk reléguant armin achète en
troisième position écoutez les
précisions de notre correspondant à
berlin peter oliver
suite au premier débat de ce site
électorale entre les candidats à la
chancellerie allemande nous n'avons pas
vraiment de gagnant clair mais nous
avons un gagnant tout de même
du parti social démocrate
après le débat le public est sondé pour
savoir qu'on aura le plus plu et 7
36% ont dit olaf scholz du parti social
démocrate frank anna-lena berbère du
parti vert à 30% hermine l'achète
conservatrice en troisième place avec
25% des voix
il a été très offensif lors de ce débat
il le fallait car sa cote de popularité
personnelle est vraiment en baisse 7 ans
si les pronostics ont longtemps fait de
lui l'héritier présomptif d'angela
merkel qui laisse sa place pour cette
élection mais son comportement lors de
plusieurs occasions médias pas gagner
les faveurs des allemands
lors du débat il a ciblé olaf scholz et
le parti social-démocrate demandant s'il
s'engageait à ne pas former de coalition
avec l'extrême gauche
il a également affirmé que le parti
écologiste et leur politique mettez en
danger l'emploi allemand notamment dans
l'industrie
l'une des raisons de cette combativité
et son manque de popularité auprès des
allemands
si nous nous remémorons les inondations
tragiques dans l'est du pays y compris
en rhénanie du nord westphalie
la région dont il est le président il a
été filmé lors d'un discours du
président allemand frank walter
steinmeier en train de rire et de
plaisanter
alors que de monsieur stand mayer
faisait part de ses condoléances et
promettez des soutiens financiers à ceux
qui avaient tout perdu
ça ne renvoie pas une belle image ça ne
fait pas bon
cette posture agressive de monsieur
l'achète n'a pas fonctionné auprès du
public mais il ne s'est pas davantage
enferré
olaf scholz qui mène d'un cheveu dans
les sondages de popularité pour le rôle
de chancelier n'a pas commis de faux pas
dimanche soir
il est actuellement ministre des
finances et vice chancelier des
représentants du partenaire mineur de la
coalition gouvernementale
il n'a pas pris de risque et n'a pas
commis d'erreur
du parti vert les plus populaires un
titre personnel que son parti en général
elle a particulièrement brillé sur les
impôts les subventions pour les foyers à
faibles revenus sommet certains
souhaitent davantage de garanties sur
jusqu'en le parti vert pourrait aller en
matière de politique climatique
en fin de compte cependant les
chanceliers ne sont pas élus sur leurs
résultats lors d'un débat
les partis eux mêmes sont déterminantes
et les sondages placent des sociaux
démocrates en tête à 24
l'union conservatrice à 21% vaud et les
verts cette semaine antoine
cela signifie qu'aucun parti n'a
suffisamment de voix pour former une
coalition gouvernementale à deux
partenaires il faudra au moins trois
parties et cela présage de négociation
très longue et très compliqué
d'avoir un ado chancelier un remplaçant
angela merkel
à la chancellerie se retrouveront lors
de débats les 9 septembre avant les
élection très serrée
et pour parler de ces futures élections
en allemagne et nous sommes avec edouard
husson historiens bonsoir edouard husson
merci d'être avec nous un mois des
législatives donc on le voit la
conscience à la succession de daniela
merkel est lancé les trois candidats qui
ont débattu hier on rappelle les
derniers sondages qui donnaient un
avantage clair au spd de la fashion's
clairement le débat d'hier at il
confirmé cette tendance
alors si vous permettez je vais un petit
peu rectifié ce que ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que il ya beaucoup
d'instituts de sondage et quand on fait
la moyenne on a plutôt un écart de 1 2
point entre le spd et la cdu ou c'est à
dire que ça reste extrêmement
serrés alors bien sûr armin laschet tu
ça a été rappelé dans le reportage a
beaucoup perdu lorsqu'il a il a été
filmé par une caméra en train de rire
alors que le président de la république
fédérale d'allemagne parlait des
inondations malgré tout est comme ça a
été dit aussi tout à l'heure les parties
vont faire l'élection c'est à dire c'est
la popularité des spectacles des parties
encore plus que celle des personnalités
qui aspire à être chancelier et dans ce
cadre là en fait la cd ou un léger
avantage sur le spd donc est-ce que le
facteur personnel olaf scholz tête de
liste du spd qui semble mieux passé va
l'emporter ou bien est ce que ce sera là
la faiblesse relative du spd par rapport
à la cd ou en tout cas bien malin ce
soir qui peut dire lequel des deux
parties va arriver en tête puisqu'on
peut exclure que le que les verts
arrivent en tête ils arriveront
peut-être en deuxième position mais
certainement pas vu les les faibles
performances de nallet naber boc au
printemps dernier une chose est sûre
c'est que il ya eu 16 ans d'un gala
merkel plutôt très populaire très
respecté et compris à l'international et
là on a un chrétien démocrate son
successeur armin laschet est loin d'être
aussi populaire pourquoi n'arrive t il
pas à bénéficier de cette popularité
dont bénéficiait la chancelière alors là
encore il faut regret il faut mettre en
perspective
angela merkel très populaire moi je
mettrais un bémol
elle a fait un très mauvais score aux
aux élections de 2017 1 puisqu'elle a
elle a fait baisser son parti à 30 2 33%
alors qu'il est qu'il était jusque-là à
41% et ella elle l'a rattrapé
partiellement sa chute de popularité
mais les allemands si vous voulez son
centre est schizophrène concernant mais
la merkel parce que d'un côté il semble
lui lui prêter un certain nombre de
vertus surtout depuis qu'elle a annoncé
qu'elle ne se représentait pas et de
l'autre ils critiquent à peu près tous
été la politique d'angela merkel que ça
soit si je fais exception des verts que
ce soit la sortie radicale de
l'industrie nucléaire que ce soit la
politique d'immigration
que ce soit la politique du coc vide
aussi parce que c'est quelque chose dont
on ne parle pas du tout mais le
mécontentement d'une partie de la
population allemande exactement comme en
france vis-à-vis d'une d'une politique
jugée trop peu en ferme east on va dire
va peser sur le sur le scrutin de du 26
septembre prochain alors un entretien
celui de l'écologiste anna lena barbeuk
inquiète est plutôt grande favorite vous
avez peut-être me dire qu'il faut mettre
en perspective
elle était favorite au printemps est
aujourd'hui en troisième position
comment comment comprendre 70 régression
entre guillemets alors anna lena bergot
qui a été très populaire
et puis il ya eu un certain nombre de
mauvaises enchaînement tourelles d'abord
des dégâts feu elle n'a pas réussi à
maîtriser le disque auquel a fait lors
du congrès de son parti elle butait
toutes les trois phrases et d'autre part
elle a été accusée de plagiat pour le
dernier livre qu'elle a publiés alors
vous savez c'est une campagne électorale
donc ça ne ça ne vole pas très haut il
n'empêche que l est est en position de
favorite et puis elle est là et la chute
et armin laschet s'il lui arrive la même
chose est-ce que olaf scholz a encore le
temps d'être dézinguer disent ils d'ici
l'élection du 26 septembre
peut-être peut-être pas nul ne peut dire
la seule chose qui est certaine c'est
que vous voyez avec trois parties autour
de 20% on est très loin de ce qu'était
la démocratie allemande au début de
l'ère merkel ou les deux grands partis
de tête avait 35 38 % et et frisait les
40 donc on peut dire que là le prochain
gouvernement allemand sera forcément à
trois parties et il aura beaucoup de mal
à décider rapidement ça va être un
changement complet et en particulier
pour nous autres français nous avons
l'habitude de nous tourner vers berlin
pour savoir ce qui a décidé à berlin
mais là à berlin on va décider des
compromis un peu laborieux et on va
aller décidé très lentement ça va avoir
des répercussions sur l'europe à suivre
donc merci edwards sont d'avoir été avec
nous avoir apporté votre aux analyses
et dans l'actualité également et c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve demain rendez-vous donc à 20h
prochain point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes avec pierre pissavy
yvernault excédent de fin de soirée atos
sphère défense
[Musique]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission